hey guys it's been a while since I did
one of these late-night videos and yeah
I kind of miss it and it always helps me
gets my thoughts together and this one
you know it kind of kind of surprised me
that I needed to just because like I've
been feeling really down lately I'm not
a hundred percent sure why contextually
it doesn't make a lot of sense logically
I like it's weird to me
because things are really good right now
you know things are going well with
videos I feel like I've been able to
have a lot of opportunities to connect
with my family to go on the last leg of
the tour
you know the cloak launch everything's
going well and yet like I can't help but
feel like something's missing you know
and I always got to hesitate because I'm
all like am i whining about something am
I just whining to whine am i complaining
about something that's not really worth
complaining about but like I can't shake
this feeling not this feeling that
something's wrong but this feeling that
I don't know like I'm waiting for
something more I'm not really one for
sitting still a lot of the time I'm
always on the move I can never stay in
the same place for too long I can never
stay in the same situation for too long
I can never commit to anything for too
long because I have this incessant need
to keep moving forward and so when it
comes down to my life if there's ever a
time when I'm stuck doing the same thing
I often get antsy but this is different
because like I've got so many different
things going on then I thought I would
have been you know a lot happier than I
am and so I mean in reality I don't
really know why and I don't know what to
make of it I have I have ideas about
what I want and ideas about things that
I need and ideas about things that are
better for the future but you know the
future is all I can think about these
days my future everyone's future
humanity's future like my thoughts are
constantly on the future
cuz coming up this will be the last few
months of my life before my birthday
next June where I'm in my 20s and not
that I'm afraid of getting older I'm
actually looking forward to getting
older like I just don't know what my 30s
are gonna be defined by you know I've
gotten to this point in my life in the
success on this channel by being so
unbelievably sure of what I needed to do
it was really obvious you know make
videos you know try to help people raise
money for charity do what I can to
better the world and yet I don't know is
it wrong of me to say like it doesn't
feel like enough that it doesn't feel
like enough but it feels like I could be
doing more you know not that it's enough
for my own self-satisfaction but it's
not enough because like I think I know
my potential I'd like to think I know my
potential anyway I want it I want to
like I don't always push myself farther
and I always want to try to improve
myself every day but I've reached this
point where I realize it there's a
possibility that I could do a lot more
with my life and I don't know what it is
I don't know I don't know the specifics
I don't know where where that would be
or what that would be I don't know what
form it would take but I just feel I
feel like everything that I've done so
far in a lot of ways is is is incredible
and I'm incredibly proud of what we've
built in terms of this community now I'm
incredibly proud of what we've done
together and I'm incredibly proud of
that but at the same time it's like I
want to do more you know I want to do
more I don't want to do more in terms of
like private things that are band-aid
fixes on a lot of problems I want to do
more to actually change the world I want
to do more to really inspire people who
maybe feel like they have no hope or
move humanity in some big way and and
that's
it seems almost ridiculous for me to say
out loud but I want to I want to inspire
change in in more people I want to push
people towards a better future like I've
always said I wanted to leave behind
more than I take I want to leave a
better world than I came into I want to
improve the world as much as I can as a
human being I want to do that and it's
easy to say that I want to do that but I
think that the thing that's getting me
down right now is like I keep saying it
and I keep saying it over and over and I
keep thinking and I keep thinking about
it in and a11 my life to mean something
and it means something right now and I
think the juxtaposition is that it does
mean something but it still doesn't feel
like I'm doing enough you know and I
know there will be people that say you
know I I do more than enough but you
know I want to see like I'm bored I'm
bored I'm sitting around a lot I'm I'm
waiting I'm I'm just kind of like
letting the clock tick by and I'm not
I'm not that kind of creature I can't do
that a Kansas City idly by while waiting
for the world to move past me I can't do
it physically can't there's a lot of
things that I can do and there's a lot
of things left for me to do in this
world but I think I can't just sit idly
by I want to a Craven my craves change
I crave moving mountains I crave doing
as much as I possibly can I crave
working myself to the bones I love it I
love everything about it I love the
potential I love the failure of it I
love trying things and not succeeding I
love that I love the experience of it it
just makes me feel alive and I want to
do something that does some kind of
tangible good more than what we've done
so far you know and no this doesn't mean
that I'm going to be quitting YouTube it
anytime soon like that's never been a
part of this the
the whole process behind these videos
it's just that I I think out loud so I
can try to get a better understanding of
what what I really want because I know
that it all ties back into a community
in one way or another what we have here
is an amazing thing there are negatives
to YouTube and the Internet in general
and social media in general but there
are positives to it is not an inherently
evil structure but the way it can be
used in the way the communities can be
band together can be but there's also
good and I think we should consider
ourselves to be very lucky to have this
opportunity to be at the center of all
this change when the world's changing
and the worlds in chaos and it can seem
dark and it can seem dreary but I think
we should still consider ourselves lucky
because we can be the catalyst to change
the world for the better and I think
that's an incredible thing I just don't
know what like that's the thing I just
don't know what but I want to so it's
it's just got me down because I don't
know I feel like I'm not living up to my
potential but at the same time it's not
really down in terms of like it's
impacting my day-to-day life it's just
making me think constantly about what
the future holds I already feel better I
think that's the thing about feeling me
rambling into the camera like this is
it's old-school way of me doing this is
it I don't know just helps me think
clearly about what's really important
and I know for a fact what's really
important is you guys
so anyway I'll close it up here I'm fine
number one first and foremost I'm fine
just cuz I say I'm a little down doesn't
mean that I'm incredibly depressed it
just means that I'm searching for
purpose and that's not a bad thing
family I'll let you guys get back to
sleep sorry for waking you or if you're
watching this in the future future go
get some sleep anyway I'm sure you'll
need it at some point so thank you
everybody so much for watching thanks
for being here thanks for like believing
in me and thanks for listening to me
ramble and thanks for helping me clear
some things up so uh thanks and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye